trash talk nation what's good it's been
years years
[Music]
little late start drock really [ __ ] us
up good
drock who has been talking about a new
episode of trash dog for
two years who confirmed last night but i
don't know if you guys know now drock's
cool now nema
which means he was probably out too late
and
nerd drock would have been here
professionally on time
bringing his normal epic energy but cool
drock
this new version of drock missed it now
i know
nerd drock lives inside of coldyrok so
he's gonna be very sad that he missed
out on this
but um this just be fun i'll show you
how i do my game
[Music]
what's your secret sauce when you go
into a negotiation first of all
if you pay the price that's something
listed for the garage sale you're
confused
my tactic is to always offer a lot less
that's also a big comment right like
this [ __ ] dick face
they asked the dollar he offered 50
cents you [ __ ] i'm like no no this
show
is for people that have 39 to their name
and we're gonna take them from this
[ __ ] episode of trash talk from 39
to 14 000 a year from now and if you've
got 39 [ __ ] dollars and somebody
wants a dollar for something that you
found on ebay is worth 29 you better
[ __ ] pay a quarter kind of like i
think about my first
offer the way i think about catching the
cold boxer
in round one in fighting you might catch
somebody cold they didn't get warmed up
that i got in it yet and you might be
able to get them out of there and round
one and that's what i'm trying to do
when i throw my first price that they
gotta listen for 15. i'm like hey would
you consider taking three
whereas most people like would you take
12 you've left no room
you come in with the three with the
insult to the [ __ ] punch to the face
you might end up getting that thing for
five worst case scenario paying eight
more fun tips always always search town
wide like in google town wide garage
sale and the weekend that you're looking
at and your state
town wide garage sale june 26th
indiana enter because you get a lot more
garage sales in a condensed area
so this show's really about let me show
you instead of telling you
[Music]
if you ride with me you can slide with
me if you feel like
550 on the fast sticky come get high
with me that's a deal right
ride with me if you ride first sale was
a super dud
why because they have jack [ __ ] for the
people at home keeping score
drock is still slow down that's a bet
right that's a deal right that's a deal
right
that's a bet right that's
[Music]
stay well no flips two fans
no flips
wish me luck
this kid's just a little too young for
me
oh my god hi hi i'm here because of you
thank you bro
what's your name jake jake nice to meet
you good luck thank you nice to meet you
okay you got me into this man yeah you
saved my life
thank you bro it makes me happy my wife
started doing this helping her mostly
look at that number my man what did you
start with
you started with 100 bucks my man so
[ __ ] proud of you
good for you
[Music]
are you filming
i know what happens when you call and it
goes directly to voicemail i'm aware of
that technology
i apologize it's okay no worries i'm
really mad this is one of my favorite
days you know now that you're cool
let's see what happens dork drock
doesn't miss trash talk cool drock
i know you're mad and like nemo's doing
everything wrong
we don't have a lob i haven't found [ __ ]
this is turning into a [ __ ] meet and
greet
i apologize i'm really sorry no worries
we'll talk soon
put on your seatbelt
[Music]
ice cold
it doesn't look happy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
all right got my first score but it's
very personal i don't even think it's a
great flip but my man levernius coles
brought me so much happiness i had to
get his jersey for two bucks
what was it list for that two i'm in a
bad mood sometimes when i'm grumpy
i don't negotiate
before they come back back and forth
back and forth coming back and forth
no internet would you do a dollar for
the bear head yeah
you got to put it on i'm definitely
pretty good i'm the [ __ ] sad bear
that's what i am
take a photo of me
that's where i'm at at this point
[Music]
he got two months to go [ __ ] load up
i have no idea what this is you know
what this is i just bought it
oh he's from the movie do you remember
bam paid a dollar for manticore mm-hmm
he goes for 17.
wow wow that's a little 12 profit
[ __ ] graduation balloons this whole
town has for people that graduated high
school
and it's [ __ ] me up why is that
because you see the balloons i think
it's garage sale but it's like ricky
graduated class of 2021 give a [ __ ]
ricky i need some garage sale flip i got
nothing
how about you this is drock's fault
pretty much
i need this panda like you need a punch
[Music]
my man nice to see you
[Music]
all they
i've never been more cold and i'm
blaming drock a hundred [ __ ] thousand
percent for this
avi let's go oh he's doing work
oh we passed it behind me yep
that little tiny tiny one oh
no it's just somebody's law
just cry
no no sure yeah it does look a little
familiar but
i'm straight ice cold i can't get [ __ ]
hopefully this one changes my luck i
[ __ ] knew i was here already
this was the first place i told you up
we went to this one
[ __ ] gave us the bad jujubes you know
we haven't been able to recover yet
yeah i get that a lot
[Music]
even when i score it's not a real score
i'll explain
it's not the right [ __ ] games inside
just the cartridge which we don't even
have
is 21 to 50 wow would you pay for it a
dollar
mario kart has [ __ ] pages of emperor
what the [ __ ] is this
drock you [ __ ]
[Music]
all right i'll come back in 30. yeah i
just don't got yourself thank you bro
no worries you're looking at old
nintendo's [ __ ]
yeah i'm sure it's in here because i got
a 20 year old perfect i'll let you know
nobody's helping me i don't know if you
guys heard nobody's healthy this is cool
like
we have never been this cold on trash
talk i've been this cold historically
right yeah this huge [ __ ]
there's 12 boxes there's 12 boxes of
them
i'm sorry do you want to finish no good
okay you get 220.
the first day will be 250. firebird
okay that's max so then anyway
all right all right
what's happening
more
[Music]
because i don't have room for the
somewhere it's very sweet
it's patient panda blades on yellow
pages
real pleasure my friend thank you well
things can change
in a second for 270 dollars we bought 12
massive boxes of japanese
magma looks so i'll just give you a let
me give you a little taste of how crazy
this gets
if you can pull over for a sec just
gonna do a little taste here here you go
just this book 35 and we paid 270 bucks
just this book there's two of them
let's let's just get one box out to like
really get everybody understand what the
[ __ ] just happened
these are japanese nagas people know
these better than i do
but what i know is i'm dangerous because
i look up [ __ ] once a while while you
count i'll explain what the [ __ ]
happened should change real [ __ ]
quick in the flip like that's how it can
happen
it can change real [ __ ] quick 270
dollars
for all these and by the way let there
be no confusion they're in the front
seat they're in the [ __ ] front seat
all right 81 series and how many
full boxes do we have it's 12 boxes 12
bucks almost a thousand books
i don't know if you know what 10 times a
thousand is nema
but that's ten [ __ ] thousand ten
bucks a book times a thousand that's
called ten thousand
what's that my man he's a big fan he
said let's go my guy
let's go my guy they're [ __ ] fans out
here do you guys [ __ ] understand what
the [ __ ] just happened we were ice cold
we couldn't have been colder
woke up at six took two shits before we
left [ __ ] cold
nothing suckasana was sucka sunning to
me [ __ ] big shout out to suck a son
of new jersey for this huge [ __ ]
score
ten 000 and cut in half say i'm going to
optimistic after seeing a ton
at 15 and 40 and all that [ __ ] call it
five thousand call five fema
five called three thousand avi we'll
call it [ __ ] three thousand
gary i can't [ __ ] do [ __ ] because i
have no money well guess what get the
[ __ ] up early
go garage sale like i've been [ __ ]
telling you now you got 3 000
you make a good little move with that
not spend it on some [ __ ] gucci's
cause you know that's what's happening
people complain they get a little
something from the government on some
free [ __ ] or they listened and did the
hustle and what do they go do
buy some nikes it's out here this is how
it starts it's [ __ ] out here
look at this people are let's see what
do we get
great not manga banggood manga somebody
just hit me up thank you jared is that
right
mangu manga good see see this is the
best part i don't even need to [ __ ]
know thank you chair mangu [ __ ]
manga hamid i'm not doing drugs my guy
you know what drug this is it's called
[ __ ] gratitude it's called optimism
it's called happiness go get a
prescription
go get a [ __ ] prescription of that
period
[Music]
you feel good about today i do if we
didn't get that one
it would have been the all-time worst
make you forgive drock a little more
no i'm very taken by the fact that you
didn't
throw in the towel that goes back to
loving the process
you know if somebody was doing this the
first time and they watched my video and
they went to like 10 of them and like
[ __ ]
it's all mindset it's optimism it's
enjoying the process for me that was
playing golf that was surfing right
so even though i was like upset because
i'm competitive i want to nail something
and i wanted to show everybody something
to
get their juices going and their ideas
flowing if you lose you lose
so just part of the game
i mean here's the recap a thousand of
these [ __ ] books they're all five to
[ __ ] 20 bucks a piece
what do you want from me i'll go look
super low five bucks each
take out bees and gas and all that
i'm lowballing this it's a 3500 flip if
you have patience two months this is
gone
at a five six thousand dollar profit if
you lack the patience and need the quick
cash you bolt the [ __ ] up and it's a
three thousand dollar flip that's
[ __ ] trash talk
see i said we ya what you need
come on
wow come on
come on
[Music]